an alarming Announcement by Russia's
President Vladimir Putin who says he's
moving nuclear weapons inside Russia's
Ally Belarus he made that announcement
in a meeting with the president of
Belarus the move would put nuclear
weapons with an easy reach of targets
inside Ukraine NATO called Vladimir
Putin's announcement irresponsible and
other Western leaders threatened new
sanctions raymian osencio has the latest
blasted by Russia beyond recognition the
situation after Russia's eight-month
assault finally stabilizing says
Ukraine's top Army Commander
now as the West deploys more weapons to
Ukraine Russian President Vladimir Putin
is raising the stakes himself
saying he will deploy tactical nuclear
weapons to Belarus with 10 Belarusian
fighter jets already retrofitted and
arguing he's doing what the U.S has been
doing for years by stationing its
nuclear weapons in Western Europe NATO
calls that misleading the White House
reacted cautiously we've insect in fact
seen no indication that he has any
intention to use nuclear weapons period
inside Ukraine nothing that would cause
us to change our own strategic deterrent
posture a top Ukraine official said the
Kremlin has taken Belarus as a nuclear
hostage NATO criticized Putin's rhetoric
as dangerous and irresponsible
and ratcheting tensions higher in Russia
an explosion about 100 miles south of
Moscow on Sunday the Kremlin claiming it
downed a Ukrainian drone injuring three
people leaving this 15-foot crater and
damaging buildings
and following Russia's nuclear threat
Ukraine is now demanding an emergency
session at the United Nations Kiev
accusing Moscow of not being a
responsible Steward of nuclear weapons
using them now for intimidation for CBS
mornings raymie inocencio Harkey of
Ukraine